well um i did not copy her um
it kind of hurt when people said that
because my
song was so emotional
and so personal to me well let's talk
about this new
song your debut song it's called
[Music]
painting
and you actually wrote the song yourself
which is
amazing kind of walk me through exactly
what inspired
the lyrics um well i wrote it during
like a really like vulnerable
time um i was dealing with a lot like
heartbreak hate um on social media like
loss of friendships and i was just going
through a lot like i moved out here
and i kind of wanted to express
how i was feeling um with my song
because a lot of people can't
really see how i truly feel through like
a 15 second tick tock video
so yeah what was that like to kind of
put
pen to paper and get so vulnerable about
those emotions i basically just like
walked in the studio and sat at the
piano and just started crying and
pouring my heart out and then that's how
it came
it's about a lot of different things
that i was going through just
a lot going on especially like the hate
the breakup obviously made it harder but
[Music]
can we expect more new music from you
and what does that timeline
kind of look like if so i'm gonna say
soon i don't know exactly when
but um i have been working on a lot of
projects with my team and i'm super
excited to share them
are you looking to do a full album an ep
at first or just kind of release singles
as they become
ready i'm not really sure like i hope so
i'd
like to do that but as of right now i
think i'm just gonna
push out a few songs and then see where
that goes
what's inspiring the new songs i feel
like this one's kind of being more like
a
like a comeback from pain if that makes
sense you know
so yeah
what was it like to record and also to
do a video and
in quarantine and with this pandemic
going on
it was very like intimate and just like
literally just like two people like
making it so i feel like
a kind of quarantine kind of benefits me
in a way because i
like am able to express myself when i
have like a small group of people
around me and people that i actually am
close with rather than like a huge
like team so save your best excuses
they can't get me through this
why were people upset that you they said
that you were like copying madison beer
which i know madison i've interviewed
her you guys are both such
different and lovely people
but how did that make you feel is there
anything else that you just want to say
about that matter
well um i did not copy her um
it kind of hurt when people said that
because my
song was so emotional
and so personal to me that when people
said that i was copying her song in her
music video it
really like kind of took away from my
feelings and what i went through
and the whole meaning behind the song we
did use rain
um both in our music videos but i think
mine this like what it symbolized for me
was way different i kind of want to show
like the endless amount of tears that i
cried during the time that i wrote the
song
and like there would be times where i
just like sit in the shower and like
ball up and just cry
and in the music video i'm just sitting
like like balling up and just letting
rainfall on me so i kind of wanted to
resemble that
um but in no means would i ever want to
copy her especially for my first song
i wouldn't want to be known for that but
um
yeah well thank you for setting the
record straight on that and i'm sorry
once again that people
like to just ruin things sometimes
not frustrating but one day we're all
going to learn it's way better to spread
love than it is to spread hate and i
hope that if anything from this
interview that's what people take away
[Music]
you said music was always the goal like
when did you first realize that you were
musical
or that you could sing and write yeah
i've been singing and writing since i
could talk
so yeah how many songs do you feel like
you have just in your arsenal like in
your back pocket
a lot there's a lot yeah hundreds
possibly honestly yeah there's a lot i
mean like i'd come home from like
kindergarten
and write about like my kindergarten
crush
so i usually put on like performances
for like my family
i had like this microphone that i
carried all the time like
i like shared a statement on tick tock
of me like when i was like four
singing um tomorrow from like annie in
like the booth so yeah
i love that do you have any other
aspirations like do you have acting
aspirations as well or do you just think
music is your lane
yeah i honestly think music is where i
want to go i can't act because i cannot
take that stuff seriously i feel like
i've laughed the entire time so
look at where it's at where do you have
like a five-year
goal plan where do you see yourself kind
of in the future with music and with
your life
in general i hope that music will
end up taking me far because i'm just so
dedicated
to it and i work super hard i'm in the
studio like
every day so um yeah i hope i can go far
with it
you